how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything mcu and this week's episode
of wanda vision
was absolutely incredible we finally
actually got some answers from this
episode now of course it did its job and
left us with even more questions like
that shocking cameo at the very end of
this episode but things are getting very
very intense and exciting in one
division
now there were very very important
things that happened in this episode of
one division some things that were
pretty obvious and some things that you
really have to search for
but all these things lead us to believe
that we know a little bit more of what
exactly is happening
in the one division series so i'm going
to break down the handful of
super important things that you need to
know about this episode
like how vision is back to life and how
wanda got to the point to where she
created this bubble
around this town and then talk about a
few villains including director
hayward the nosy neighbor agnes and
spoiler warning if you have not seen the
episode yet and don't want any spoilers
quicksilver at the end that's right i
think quicksilver is
actually going to be one of the villains
of the show and i'll break it all down
right now if you're new to the channel
and you love marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so this episode starts with wanda and
vision both holding one twin in their
hand they're trying to get them to go to
sleep but they just
won't now it's very subtle but wanda
asks vision to go
get the pacifier so she can attempt to
use magic on the babies
she doesn't want vision to see this this
becomes more apparent throughout the
episode as wanda wants to do things that
vision doesn't necessarily agree with
but her magic doesn't work it doesn't
put them to sleep and in fact it kind of
does the opposite it kind of makes them
laugh a little bit
now this isn't the first time that we
haven't seen wanda's magic work
in episode 3 when she actually had the
babies there was a stork that came in
and her magic didn't work on the stork
this implies that the stork and the
twins could actually be from a different
source of magic
a stronger source which is why her magic
doesn't work
wanda would go on to say or we could
possibly need help taking care of the
twins and of course
right as she says that right on cue here
comes the nosy neighbor
agnes she rings the doorbell and vision
goes oh and he runs to grab a pillow to
hide his face because he wasn't
transformed into a human yet
he hides his face behind a couch pillow
transforms his face to look like a human
and says hello
now i think everybody has figured out by
now that agnes isn't just another normal
person inside this town that wanda has
under her spell agnes clearly knows what
is happening and it's actually pretty
revealing in the first scene here
she said that she was on her way to
jazzercise but she heard that the twins
couldn't sleep
vision is kind of suspicious and he says
who told you that and she actually gets
a little bit taken back for a second and
goes
uh but then quickly says my ears vision
laughs but he still looks very
suspicious of her and then agnes drops a
very particular line she says anti-agnes
is here and i've got
a few tricks up my sleeve agnes goes to
hold the kids but vision kind of freaks
out
and says no this is where things get
very intense and very odd
agnes kind of stops like something went
wrong looks at wanda and says
do you want me to take that again
meaning do another take of the scene to
where it would end up differently
to where she would hold the kids as she
says you want me to hold the kids
she then says should we just take it
from the top and she puts her bag back
on like she's gonna walk back outside
and come in and do it again
so agnes clearly knows what is happening
she clearly knows
that wanda is controlling whatever is
going on
and she knows that if wanda doesn't like
the way things are going
she can redo it so this proves that
agnes isn't just some random person
in the town she's a person with a very
specific meaning
in the show as she knows that wanda is
controlling
everything now wanda would eventually
say vision let's let
agnes give it a try but vision is still
very very confused and he takes wanda to
the side and asks her what that was
about
but wanda denies really having seen
anything now this is a very important
part that happens right here
agnes starts to spray what she calls a
lavender spray
over the twin saying it's supposed to
have a calming effect and then she says
that her husband
ralph sprays it on her every night
now this is yet again another mention of
her husband ralph who we have never
seen ralph has yet to show his face in
the one division series
but what's very interesting is that not
too long after agnes sprays the lavender
on the twins
all of a sudden they age up now agnes
goes on to say that she's looking for
wanda envisions
dark liquor not for her but for the kids
and it's very interesting that they put
an emphasis on dark liquor because we
believe
agnes to be agatha hartness a witch
somebody who can perform
dark magic she says i'm just gonna go
check in there and then all of a sudden
the babies stop
crying wanda and vision notice and all
of a sudden they realize the kids aren't
in the cribs anymore and then they hear
mommy daddy and turn around to see that
their twin boys are now
grown a few years and it's extremely
shocking to not only vision but wanda as
well
implying that she doesn't really have
control over the twins
so could it have been the spray that
agnes put over them that could have
caused this
more on that in a bit but going back to
wanda's magic
not being able to control the kids this
is hinted at again
by agnes she says kids
can't control them no matter how hard
you try
and then one in vision seem to just
accept the fact that their kids are now
grown up and they go and embrace them in
their arms
we then cut to a very 80s sitcom opening
and the whole entire
time the music and what were being shown
in the beginning leads us to believe
that wanda is controlling
everything but the absolute best part of
this
intro is seeing a baby vision it's
absolutely adorable and hilarious
now one thing it does reveal in the
intro is the age of the twins
we see them celebrating a birthday and
on the cake are the numbers
one through five meaning they are five
years old the intro ends and we pick up
where we left off last episode with
monica rambo
now there's a very very hidden part in
this scene that is very
important director hayward is talking to
monica as she's being examined he asks
what's the first thing you remember and
she says
pain the pain of being pulled into the
town through the energy barrier
she then says she heard wanda's voice
and this is most likely her putting a
spell
over her then she says there was this
feeling keeping me down
this hopeless feeling and then she says
it was grief
now during this time there is very very
quickly
less than half of a second an image of
wanda
crying shown in this image that is very
quickly shown wanda is clearly crying
and grieving but if you look at the
background of this image
it does appear to be westview however
this appears to be before she took the
town hostage
now as we learn in an upcoming scene
wanda
found vision's body that sword had and
she put it back together
and recreated him however i think this
is in between
i think she went and gathered all the
body parts for vision
took them and when she was around
westview had a mental breakdown
and kind of just exploded creating this
bubble
around this town where her magic
controls everybody or so we're believed
to think
again more on that later on but this
next scene is also very important monica
gets off the table she is cleared and
then jimmy wu
and darcy come in the nurse says that
she's going to need to do the tests
again
because they're blank she then says
she's going to need to take more blood
as well
now for those of you who do not know
monica rambo in the comics
actually has superpowers and she's known
as the hero
spectrum and for a while she even held
the title of captain marvel
but in the comics she was exposed to a
ton of extra dimensional
energy giving her powers she gains the
ability of appearance alteration
superhuman speed strength flight energy
manipulation
intangibility meaning she can phase
through things and invisibility
she also has cosmic awareness now these
tests probably don't work because
there's probably an insane amount of
extra dimensional energy in her right
now
after all she did go through an energy
barrier created by
possibly the strongest hero in the
marvel cinematic universe right now
so it looks like this is definitely
going to be how she got her powers
either by going through this energy
field
or by wanda using her powers to force
her out so it looks like you just
watched an origin story for the hero
spectrum then it goes to a sword
briefing where it says they now have
somebody who has been inside who can
tell them firsthand what's going on
director hayward says that they thought
wanda was a victim but she is actually
the victimizer
jimmy then takes the floor and talks a
little bit about wanda's backstory and
her brother and her mother and father as
well
it says her parents were killed in an
air raid when her and patreon were
10. director hayward then says the twins
were subsequently radicalized by
volunteering for hydra in which jimmy
says that's an
oversimplification but yes and director
hayward
did not like that at all now i've talked
a few times this week about how director
hayward
could be a villain and it's looking more
and more like he
is there's a lot of talk about him being
mephisto or perhaps nightmare but for
right now i
actually just think he's kind of just an
evil human being who wants to get rid of
wanda
jimmy says the mind stone gave wanda her
powers and hayward says back up a minute
and we get the biggest tease of all time
from
marvel hayward says doesn't maximoff
have an
alias or a funny nickname of some sort
of course he is referring to her name of
the scarlet
witch something that we have been told
she is actually going to be called
in this series however they didn't give
it to us in this episode but we were so
close jimmy says no she didn't have one
single nickname like that
agent hayward then says she fought
against the avengers but then jimmy says
yes right before joining them and
helping them save the world
and we find out that jimmy's just a
great guy who doesn't like speaking ill
about anybody
director hayward then goes on to say
that wanda is now a terrorist
monica rambo goes on to defend wanda
saying she's not a terrorist but hayward
brings out some records stating that
monica said
the experience inside the energy bubble
with wanda was excruciating
terrifying and a violation the two argue
about whether wanda is a terrorist or
not but monica believes that wanda
is still good she believes that she took
to town hostage but then put her own
barrier up to keep it from spreading
this is more evidence that wanda had
some sort of a mental breakdown and kind
of exploded but it appears that she
caught it and
contained it and then we finally get an
answer as to
how vision is actually alive director
hayward says that he received permission
to
show a certain surveillance video to his
squad
the video is of a sword facility where
vision's body was being held
and it really wasn't being held it was
being experimented on if we take a look
at the surveillance footage we can see
that vision is completely torn apart
all of his appendages are separated from
his torso
both legs both arms and his head and as
director hayward states
wander breaks into the facility takes
the parts of vision's body
and resurrects him now something to note
here the footage doesn't
actually show wanda taking his body it
doesn't show her resurrecting him
either this is all based of what
director hayward has been saying and
it's very clear from this episode that
he does not
like wanda he thinks she's a terrorist
and will probably say
anything to make her look like the bad
guy so although this does appear to be
what happened with wanda and vision and
his resurrection
there is a chance that he could be lying
now jimmy says that it is against the
sokovia accords for wanda to actually do
that
hayward says it was also against
vision's will and jimmy says
vision did not want to be made into a
weapon now we can assume what vision was
referring to
was that he did not want to be turned
into ultron
given the fact that he was kind of
supposed to be ultron but sword was
experimenting on him
as well they could have been trying to
weaponize him and his technology
themselves and we've heard
ultron's name dropped a couple of times
in the wanavision series
and depending on what happens we could
see the resurrection of
ultron in the marvel cinematic universe
hayward pegs wanda to be the villain and
then dismisses the meeting
but then jimmy asks a very important
question after the meeting how did she
resurrect
vision without the mind stone well based
off of the very first
one of vision trailer that we got and
some tv spots in between
we have seen the mine stone and we're
pretty confident that this is actually
footage of
her trying to actually recreate the mine
stone and in this footage it looks like
there is an explosion
possibly her failing at creating it and
this could be what sent her over the
edge
her having a mental breakdown of her not
being able to revive vision without the
mind stone then darcy asks the very
important question
what happens when he learns the truth we
then go back into
wanda's reality for a very cute scene
where wanda's twin boys who can now walk
and again are five years old are washing
a dog so they can present it to their
mother and father
as a clean dog so that they might keep
it wanda comes in discovers the dog and
the twins begged their mom for a chance
to keep the puppy
vision comes in and discovers the puppy
as well but he's also disguised as a
human at the moment
and want to ask why and he says he has a
hunch that somebody might just pop over
any moment
and right on cue is agnes the neighbor
with all of the stuff needed to take
care of a dog
which vision notices she asked if they
named the dog and right as she asked
this the dog
licks an electrical outlet and sparks
fly off agnes suggests sparky as the
name
wanda loves it and right in front of
agnes creates a
dog collar for sparky with her magic and
here's where things kind of start to
take a weird turn
vision is very freaked out he says you
did that right in front of her
that's not what we agreed upon wanda
sort of brushes it off saying that she
didn't notice but vision says
we agreed to not do magic in front of
people and then
wanda says i'm tired of hiding this is
very different than the first few
episodes where wanda wanted to blend
in and not let anybody know about them
she tried very hard in the beginning to
conceal her powers and now it seems like
she doesn't really care
if anybody knows and she tells vision
that maybe he doesn't have to hide
either
this is extremely concerning to vision
he says normally they typically view
eye-to-eye and are on the same mind but
now he suspects something and he asks
wanda what aren't you telling me
but as things start to get intense the
twins ask if they can keep the dog
wanda and visions say they don't think
they're ready to take care of a dog
until they're at least 10 years old the
twins look at each other
smile and then all of a sudden age
themselves to
10 years old and this is extremely
surprising to wanda
proving that this wasn't her magic that
aged them now agnes was
in front of them the entire time she
literally watched them age
up and it didn't faze her at all in fact
she made a joke stating that she hopes
the dog doesn't actually age and stays
the same age
again showing us that she's not actually
under wanda's spell
she plays a bigger role in this we then
go back to monica rambo
darcy and jimmy who is the champion of
the episode because he
finally got darcy the coffee that she's
been wanting i also think these two
might get together which i'm not unhappy
about i would actually like to see that
but monica and darcy are talking about a
way to
enter the energy field again they've
basically figured out a very scientific
approach to getting inside this energy
bubble
and she did mention photons and that is
actually a name that she carried at one
point in time and her mother was called
maria photon rambo so basically they
discovered a very scientific way to
enter the energy field and monica
actually says that she knows an
aerospace engineer
who would be up for the challenge now
this is a
very specific reference now i believe
this could be a
setup for reed richards of the fantastic
four in disney's investor day kevin
feige the president of marvel studios
came out and said that they are
currently right now
working on a fantastic four feature they
also revealed the official logo for the
fantastic four film that is going to be
coming
this means they have their actors that
are going to be playing reed richard sue
storm
johnny storm and ben grimm and reed
richards is the smartest man
on earth in the marvel universe smarter
than tony stark bruce banner
anybody and he's considered to be a
master of all
sciences but as we know he built the
marvel one which was a spaceship to take
him and the fantastic four into space
that is definitely aerospace engineering
so is monica talking about
reed richards it appears that it could
be so and reed richards could be
this awesome cameo that we've been
hearing about that paul bettany's been
talking about and elizabeth olsen has
been talking about as well
and we know that the fantastic four are
coming to the mcu
relatively soon so this could be the
first mention
of the fantastic four in the marvel
cinematic universe
now the next part is very important
jimmy wu asks if they have identified
the twins the infant twins and the
grown-up twins
he thinks they're actors but monica
tells him they're not they're actually
wanda's kids and they actually are aging
this fast and the reason that this
is extremely important is it shows that
wanda can actually create
life yes so far she has taken over
people but she actually created her twin
boys
and when this energy field is gone i
believe they will still be
there meaning that she can take people
from one reality and bring them
into another which i think is going to
play a huge part
down the road and something cool
mentioned is that we kind of get a
confirmation that wanda would have
killed thanos if he wouldn't initiated a
blitz
so wanda is indeed insanely strong
probably the most powerful being
on planet earth at this point then we
have a little bit of awkwardness
monica says nobody else came close to
defeating thanos and jimmy wu says i
would argue that captain marvel came
close
and this is seemingly very upsetting to
monica now remember her mother
was carol danvers aka captain marvel's
best friend
but her mother also did get cancer and
there's a great possibility that her
mother being exposed to space and a
bunch of different types of energy and
radiation
from captain marvel could be the cause
of why she got cancer
and ultimately died during the five year
blip so this could be the reason that
monica is very bitter towards
captain marvel and it is very obvious
that she's bitter judging how she
dismissed darcy talking about captain
marvel and darcy's reaction to her
we then get yet another very important
scene monica jimmy and darcy realized
that monaco's clothes were changed when
she entered the bubble they discovered
that wanda
is literally altering reality which is
straight from the comics it's one of her
powers
but her reality also ends up breaking in
the comics which is something that we
will most likely see in the series
also it's worth noting that darcy has
named what wanda is doing
a hex now obviously in the comics wanda
the scarlet witch
does hex's spells but darcy says that
she named it that based off the
hexagonal shape of the bubble around it
we then go to vision's
work he's bringing his work into the
future with his synthazoid skills they
now have internet and they receive a
communication from sword
the whole office reads it but then
brushes it off which is very alarming
the vision he then absorbs what appears
to be the email into him and then he
awakens
norm norm immediately freaks out
realizing that he is no longer being
controlled
he searches for his phone to call his
family and vision tells him to explain
what's going on
norm then says you have to stop her
she's in
my head none of it is my own it hurts
it hurts so much just make her stop
vision then puts him back to how he was
before and the norm
immediately goes back to normal being
controlled
now i think that this is a bit of
misdirect from marvel he never
said wanda and he definitely knows
wanda's name and he knows that wanda is
vision's wife
but he didn't say make wanda stop or
make your wife stop
it was very vague not specific at all
the only thing specific about it was
her we know that it's a woman so
although we're led to believe it's wanda
and it definitely is
wanda to some extent i don't think wanda
is the main person behind this
i think this is agatha harkness or as we
know her right now
agnes again she's always there and she's
unfazed when things magically happen
like the twins grow up all of a sudden
it's very clear that she is involved in
this somehow and since norm was
so vague i believe he's talking about
her but again wanda is partly
responsible as we see
the next scene is of wanda and her twin
boys training the dog
the boys then say they're going to go
see their dad but wanda says he's at
work
they then note that it's saturday he
doesn't work on saturday but want to
said that he had to go in
the boys think it's because he doesn't
want to see the two twins but wanda
explains that
sometimes her and vision aren't on the
same page
and he needed a distraction this means
that she
sent him off to work meaning that she
does indeed have
some control over him and the reality
around them
but the twins ask wanda if she has a
brother and she says
i do but she doesn't say he's dead she
says he's far away from here and that
makes her sad at some times
now from here there are four major
events that take place that completely
changed the way that we view the show
the first one is sword sending in a
drone to try and talk to wanda
monica is piloting the drone with
director hayward and others behind her
the twins and wanda go outside
they see the drone and monica tries to
talk to wanda but wanda just gets mad
her eyes turn red hayward decides it's
not working and says
take the shot the drone then fires at
wanda and her children this obviously
concerns monica as she didn't know that
that was the plan
then they go to the perimeter where
wanda actually
walks out of the energy bubble dressed
in her scarlet witch outfit
holding the drone in her hand she throws
the drone at
all the sword agents that are
surrounding her and says is this yours
hayward says it was a precaution you
can't blame us and she says
this is your only warning stay out of my
home monica then steps in and says you
are the one in control of the town in
which wanda looks at her and says
you're still here and brings out some
magic in her hand
like she's about to attack her monica
then tries to tap
into the goodness of wanda she says
wanda brought her into the reality
let her help her give birth and she's a
telepath meaning she can read people's
minds
so she knows that monica wants to help
and says let me help
but wanda says what could you possibly
give me monica says
what do you want and wanda says i have
what i want and nobody will ever take it
from me again
she then controls all of the sword
soldiers and turns them
on hayward she walks towards the energy
field and looks like she
puts a hex on the energy field probably
making it even harder
for people to get through we then cut to
a commercial for lagos where it says
lagos for when you make a mess but
didn't mean to now this is a call back
to captain america civil war in lagos
where wanda ended up killing a bunch of
people with that explosion
but she didn't mean to she was just
trying to save captain america
the next important scene is sparky has
gone missing the twins and wanda are
looking for him and the mailman makes a
very interesting
comment when talking about the missing
dog he says don't worry i'm sure he'll
come up
your mom won't let him get too far it
would appear that the mailman
kind of knows who wanda is that she's
kind of controlling everything but wanda
doesn't even think about it and keeps
looking for the dog
eventually good ol agnes who just pops
up everywhere at the most convenient
times comes out with the dog
wrapped in a blanket stating that the
dog had died and here we get a very
interesting and very important moment as
the twins are grieving they say it's too
sad
and wanda tells them to not age up again
she doesn't control this
she says the urge to run from this
feeling is powerful
i know obviously referring to her
brother and vision and also the fact
that she made up a perfect reality for
herself
running from her own problems but the
twins then say it's too sad
you can fix anything mom fix the dead
and wanda
is extremely shocked and it appears that
agnes
is actually genuinely shocked as well
but i don't think that she's shocked
that wanda has magic i think she knows
that already i think she's shocked that
she's so powerful
to bring people back to life because if
she is indeed working for mephisto
or the grim reaper that's clearly not a
good thing for them
that wanda can resurrect people but
wanna goes on to tell the boys that
there are some rules that you can't
break
like aging and bringing people back from
the dead which again leads me to believe
that perhaps
hayward was lying about what wanda did
maybe wanda
didn't actually bring vision back to
life but we'll see how that plays out we
then go back to wanda and vision's home
where
vision comes in and says i spoke to norm
i unearthed the man's suppressed
personality and i spoke to him free of
your oversight
and he states that he was in pain wanda
then tries to avoid talking about it and
asks if they can do something else and
vision interjects and says you can't
control me
like the others but wanda says can't i
and she starts to roll
her own end credits of the tv show that
they're living
but vision doesn't let her go he asked
what is the maximoff anomaly
he says he believes that she created
this all at first
subconsciously and that she only
recently became aware of it but wanda
still denies it and then vision
actually gets really mad he says norm
has a family
and he tells wanda to stop lying to him
and he flies in the air like he's ready
to fight
wanda then says i'm doing all of this
for us so let me handle this
vision asks what's outside of west view
and juana says you don't want to know
and vision gets enraged and says you
don't get to make that decision for me
wanda says you've never talked to me
like this before and vision says before
what i can't remember my life before
westview i don't know who i am
i'm scared wanda says do you really
think i'm doing all of this
do you think i'm controlling every
single person in westview
then she says i don't know how any of
this started in the first place
and then vision comes to her side and
says oh wanda what you're doing here
is wrong and right when wanda looks like
she may be ready to deal with what is
actually happening
the doorbell rings every time something
is about to go down and get real
a distraction of some sort happens and
keeps wanda and vision from talking
about it
wanda says i didn't do it but vision
doesn't believe her however i do truly
think that she didn't do it at least
not consciously now we're about to talk
about the biggest spoiler of the series
so far
so if you don't want to know it click
away now wanda opens the door and lo
and behold it's her brother quicksilver
however
it is not aaron taylor johnson not the
quicksilver from age of
ultron but in fact is evan peters is
quicksilver from the
fox universe now i know there's a lot of
confusion about this but it's all going
to unravel soon and keep in mind that
the movie that evan peters played
quicksilver in was based
in the 80s and it's an 80s episode of
one division
now we're unsure if wanda did this or
somebody else did this but one thing
is for sure universes are colliding
this is technically the first x-men in
the
mcu this is the quicksilver from the fox
x-men universe he is an x-men and he is
now in the mcu
so yes technically this is our first
x-men in the marvel cinematic universe
now right now the biggest question is
who exactly is behind this
is it indeed wanda or is it an outside
force like
agatha is it somebody like mephisto or
the grim reaper i personally think that
it started off as
wanda having some sort of a mental
breakdown she lost her brother who we
are seeing in the show now she lost
vision who of course she apparently
resurrected
it's understandable but is it just her
controlling all of these people because
at the end it truly seemed
like she wasn't the one when she was
saying do you really think it's me
she may have gone along with it and
accepted some control over some people
but it looks like there is still
another force there agnes is definitely
one of them
it's clear that she knows what's going
on it's clear that she knows when things
are going to happen because she
magically shows up
and the twins specifically seem to be of
an interest to her and remember in the
comics the twins are actually shards of
the soul
of mephisto could she be working for him
or could she be working for somebody
like the grim reaper or nightmare
either way i think wanda is not 100
behind everything but let me know what
you think in the comments down below and
what did you think about that possible
fantastic four easter egg and what do
you think about now technically the
x-men
being in the mcu be sure to let me know
in the comments down below if you love
marvel don't forget to subscribe and hit
the notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof